you've been given an equation that tells
you about
the velocity squared of some particular
particle in terms of displacement now
just um
have a look at this last line that we've
written here what that essentially means
is if you get some expression for
velocity squared
in terms of displacement and it's this
it's a quadratic
but it's concave down as it were right
you've got a
negative leading coefficient in this
case it's negative 2.
even though it doesn't look anything
like a trigonometric function or like
our original
differential equation that we started
with minus n squared x minus c
when you see this what we've just shown
is that that's simple harmonic motion
that's a bit of an indicator for us okay
what we want to do is two things number
one we want to show that it is
simple harmonic motion like how can we
tell that's actually the easy part
and then secondly once we get past that
we want to know these particular
qualities of the simple hum motion
excuse me period center of motion
range and amplitude though you'll see
range and amplitude are really kind of
two halves of the same thing okay so
this is the situation let me jot down
what we're having look at here uh our v
squared this is our example what's it
equal to it's
negative 2x squared what's the rest of
it i just can't read it for me
thank you okay
so first step i want to prove that this
is simple harmonic motion now
i've kind of got two uh
tools in my toolbox for working out
whether something is simple harmonious
or not
i've got all of those time equations uh
a sine and t plus alpha plus a constant
or a
cos nt plus alpha etc or i've got that
other tool the one that we started with
today
not the time equations but the
this this displacement this differential
equation right
in this situation which one is going to
be more useful to me
it's it's going to be this uh
differential equation isn't it
because there's no time to be seen here
right so therefore differentiating with
respect to time
not very useful i need to differentiate
with respect to x
in order to get like velocity sorry
acceleration in here somewhere
i need a half v squared don't i i don't
have a half a squared at the moment
that's no problem i'll just multiply
everything through by
a half and now you're seeing why
all of those coefficients were even
it was just to make things easy for us
okay so far so good i've got a half v
squared now
what am i going to do with that like
under any
motion situation i can differentiate
that with respect to
x i mean it all is in terms of x right
so let's go ahead and do that
i've got my d half v squared on dx on
the left hand side where you get on the
right
it's a polynomial guys you can do it
yeah
you're like i'm an extension two i
question everything now right it's a
minus
two x plus four good
okay where can i take this what is the
left hand side equal to
by definition this is acceleration
x double dot and then what i want on the
right hand side is something
of that format okay what am i going to
factorize out
uh two i can go better than two i'm
gonna go minus two right
minus two out the front and that leaves
me with x
minus two because of that double
negative there right so
number one have i proven that it is
simple hormone motion
tick this is the differential equation
that i wanted that's the first thing and
now i need to try and work out all the
rest of the pieces which are not
too arduous right off of this equation i
can read off two of the four things
they're asking me for
what are the two things that are just
like on the face of it
center of motion which part is the
center of motion it's the two right
here is the center i'm going to say the
center is
x equals to a nail have we proven that
oh sure i really at this point should
say therefore
uh is it a particle an object what is it
it's a particle particle
is in simple harmony motion
thank you emmanuel for being diligent
there we go
because it satisfies the differential
equation that is the definition of
simple harmony motion
uh okay we were part way through we got
the center what was the other thing that
you can tell me straight off of the
differential equation
it's the period it just takes a hold on
period yes
takes a teeny bit of a step but we can
do it right the period comes from
if i come back over here it comes from n
right it's going to be 2 pi
on m so in this case just be careful
right
what is the actual n in this equation
it's root 2 because that's a minus n
squared right there okay
so therefore since n equals the square
root of two
that implies that the period will be
two pi on that two pi on
root two yes
two divided by row two last i checked
was root two because that's what root
two means
so therefore i have root two pi do i
have any units
i don't think so usually it's seconds
but you get the idea i'll just leave
that as time units there
i've got the center i've got the period
at this next moment you have to think
for a second
i am now looking for range and amplitude
range and amplitude
i won't call you but i'm just curious to
know how many people immediately already
know
what to do to work out range or
amplitude hands up i just want to get a
rough indication
two three four okay all right hands down
thank you i'm glad you know
but for the rest of you call yourself
back we're sort of in the lucky position
that we've got all that working from
today still on the board
i can pull the same trick that i did
back over here to work out that constant
integration
i can pull the same trick that i did
here to work out
where my range is i even used the
actually no i'll use the wrong word i
said domain but you get the idea because
i was thinking about x's right
the range of motion is how far can you
go right what are the limits of your
motion
we have the limits of motion on the
board we use them to evaluate this
constant integration
right what are the limits of motion
it's it's your center plus or minus your
amplitude and that's one of the things
that we're being asked for right
the reason why this is helpful is
because i know
at those extremes of motion what the
velocity is and i have a velocity
equation right here you see that
so if i can substitute in the velocity
being zero bam
this thing cancels and then i can solve
this to find
well where are those extremes of motion
once you've got that you kind of have
range
and amplitude in one fell swoop so can
we do that
i think i don't need this all so i'm
going to go down to about
there i'll leave this because this is
the fact we're about to use
and because i'm introducing a new line
of argument
i want to say what i'm doing so at the
extremes of motion
or act the extremities
velocity equals zero yes so i'm going to
go right back to the original question
today's marker and i'm going to say well
therefore i can substitute into
that first equation 0 squared equals
negative 2x squared plus 8x
plus 10. of course we know we can divide
3 by this we divided through by two last
time but i can be
even lazier divide through by negative
two
and that gives me a really delightfully
simple
quadratic did i do it right did i divide
through correctly
yeah i'm just watching for the negatives
there can you help me factorize
x minus 5 x x minus 5
and x plus 1 x plus
1 is that right
multiplies to that adds to that looks
good to me so then
x gives me two values um
negative to two plus minus three say it
again
negative two plus minus three negative
two plus minus three so
you've already gone to working out your
center and your amplitude i'm just going
to write down my solutions
first okay and i know firstly there's my
range right there's a low or the most
negative i can get in the negative
direction there's the most positive
but that's really saying well because i
already know right over here what my
center of motion is
right there's the center and how far do
i go
to get to either of those i go three
units
sorry as is often the case you're like
three steps ahead of me okay
so i've got my central motion from that
i can read off amplitude
and this line right here is already the
range okay range here
amplitude here
how do you feel about that again so i
factorized out the
minus two and i've completed the square
yep i didn't use b is equal to zero sure
they did the square oh sorry so you're
back on
sort of this or like this line this line
well you need a minus sign don't you
yeah a minus sign here so everything
goes
like we had over there yep and i got it
into the form of
n squared a squared minus x
yeah excellent okay so just in case
you're not following right essentially
anger has pulled this trick right which
is clever because this trick has or
rather this line this
equation has an a in it which is kind of
the thing that i'm looking for right
this in some ways is a rather indirect
way of going about it because you find
range and amplitude comes from the right
this is actually sort of in some ways a
more direct way to get to a because a is
in that equation right
and i guess you've got nine here right
yeah yeah because you that's what you
have to add to complete
uh that square that one there yep
hard and square yeah that's right um
thankfully we all get the same answer
so which we shouldn't be surprised by
because these are all the same equations
does that make sense you're happy so let
me pause there and just make sure we
know what we're doing okay
in order to use uh equations of
in order to work with equations of this
form we just need to remember we've got
the definition
for simple harmonic motion from the
differential equation and then
uh no i rubbed it off this time uh now
here it is
our generally in for all motion
not even not simple harmonic this is
always true so we can use that to number
one
search for simple home motion and then
integrate up and get expressions like we
saw here
to let you work out amplitude